The center will be at negative 1 negative 2 the opposite signs of these and a
value is 3 and the b value is 2. Nice thinking if you got these right. Now
let's check out your graph. We'll start by graphing an ellipse and the center
is at negative 1 negative 2. We'll go one unit to the left, and two units down.
Now we use our a and b values to get the other points. Three units in the x
direction for a, and two units in the y direction for b. We carefully construct
our rectangle around our ellipse. This is going to start our hyperbola graph.
Next, we draw on our two diagonals across the rectangle. And now we're ready to
draw on our hyperbola. Our hyperbola will open left and right, since the x
squared term comes first. So we'll cut open our ellipse, and we'll split the
two halves outward. We'll stretch the ends of the hyperbola to our diagonals,
which gives us our final graph. Keep in mind, that the reason this parabola
opened left and right was because the x squared term came first. It was
positive in this case. We use the opposite signs for h and k to get our center,
negative 1 and negative 2. These are some of the most common pit falls students
make. So you want to make sure you pay close attention to signs and which term
comes first for hyperbolas.